What's up everybody!
We are Pongfinity
And welcome to another episode of
Challenge Pongfinity
This is the series where YOU
Challenge US
With your craziest ideas related to table
tennis.
If your idea gets picked
We'll feature it in our next video
And give you a shout out.
So make sure you leave your comments and ideas
In the comment-section below!
This one is from PokeExpert Thunderbolt
Let's do some push-ups!
Eric Primeau wants me to play against myself
while doing backspin.
Let's see how many shots I can do!
Next one is from Dude that's amazingly perfect.
We are going to play a rally of 10 shots
On each of these 4 tables.
Eryk Ozarowski suggests we should play with
a balloon.
Thanks for watching guys!
Hope you enjoyed this episode as much as this
horse enjoys me!
Remember to subscribe to our channel here
And watch our previous videos there.
Until next time!